as you build your wealth there are
people who you will need to help you and
have in your arsenal
that means lawyers accountants
investment professionals uh people who
you uh invest with so those are
different things people you do deals
with people you do business with people
you might get mentorship from
and
selecting the right people can make or
break your life and the trajectory of
your business i can tell you that
firsthand i would not be where i am
today
if i didn't have the mentors and
advisors and counsel that i've received
over the years
and over time one of the hardest things
is trying to figure out who you're going
to trust and what's the process that you
have to go through in order to find
those people and so having done this for
a you know a while and we've you know
moved a lot of money in our businesses
and for those who don't know me my name
is alex for mozzie i'm a portfolio of
companies that does about 85 million a
year i have nothing to sell you and the
whole goal for this channel is to
document our journey from uh 85 million
a year to a billion dollars a year in
revenue in our portfolio and just share
the lessons that we've learned along the
way and so
i've boiled this down to two things two
traits uh that you can look for so i try
to make this as simple as possible and i
don't just do this review i do it for me
because i think you know we're kind of
in this together and this crazy thing we
call life anyway so the two things that
i look for and then i'll show you the
tests that i think through for each of
them so the first is integrity and i
know that might sound silly but when you
like think about it you need someone who
you can trust like if you're giving
someone your money like or you're trying
to take someone's advice or counsel you
need to trust their intentions all right
and so it's not just whether they have
integrity it's whether they have your
best interest in mind all right so i'm
going to get to how i solve for that in
a second but that is the first character
trait of you need that you need of a
council of somebody of any kind of
council really whether it's investment
law et cetera
the second
is efficacy or their skill set right so
let's think of both let's think of just
different scenarios here so let's say
you might trust your mom implicitly but
she doesn't have the skill of knowing
much about you know how to structure
insurance policies or trusts or you know
investments in tech startups right she
might not have that skill but you might
trust her intention right for you
specifically on the reverse of that you
might see that there's this person who's
got lots of skill is prodigious in this
but it also means that they know exactly
how to screw you if they want to right
which is one of the double-sided things
of being really good at something right
you know all the details you know how to
write the agreement structure the deals
in order to make sure that you you know
get the best outcome right and so the
idea is to find someone who has both
your best interests at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
since you're like well yeah
maybe that seems obvious for me just
even boiling it down to that was very
helpful for me because when i look and i
look through advisors look for people i
want to get counsel from i have to look
at these two things all right so here's
how i test for the integrity piece and
here's how you can kind of like you can
control for risk here right one is i
always try and interview as many
advisors as humanly possible all right
um and i do that because i'm gonna get
as much information from each of the
council during this process that will
give me perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks to 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well i guess this is it right i guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgement yet and so the first step in
this is that i interview as many as as i
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where i reach out to my network
i make posts et cetera to try and get as
many referrals as i can all right so
that's step one step two for the
integrity piece is that i try and have a
line incentives now a lot of times
they're incentive systems that appear
aligned but not are not in reality so
let me give you an example so in the
real estate market if you're a realtor
for example you may think oh this
realtor has my best interest at heart
right because they have an incentive to
sell the house and so that is why
they're going to get compensated so they
want to sell it for as much as possible
ah
but they aren't incentivized to sell it
for as much as possible they're
incentivized to sell as fast as possible
and get the deal closed right and so
think about this
for you selling a house for five hundred
thousand dollars that's worth five
hundred thousand dollars
is a normal you know that like that's
normal that's the market price right but
for you to make an extra let's say
twenty five thousand or fifty thousand
dollars would be really material that
would be a huge extra outcome for you
you would probably push a lot harder to
get the extra 25 or 50 000
now let's say that um you could probably
sell it in a day at 450 000 because it's
below the market value of the house
right now here's what's crazy is that if
a a selling realtor you know like total
it might be seven percent two percent
goes to the buyer and five percent goes
to the seller if five percent is going
to your realtor five percent of five
hundred thousand dollars right is 25
grand
okay and so for them
the the 50 000 decrease to drop you from
500 to 450 means that they're going to
give up 2 500 so they're gonna make
twenty two thousand five hundred so let
me ask you a question now the reverse if
they sell for 525 they're going to get
27 500 right and so it's a 5 000 swing
off of a you know 25 000 nut for them
and one of them might take them three
months and one of them might take them a
day so what is their incentive
their incentive is to get is to make as
much money as possible per unit of time
and so they're incentivized to sell as
fast as possible and so this is one of
those things where you have to put your
thinking cap on and say are our
incentives truly aligned and so when
we're looking at this when i say there's
two aspects that i look for counselor or
somebody who's going to help me do
something financially legally insurance
wise whatever it is so first is that
integrity piece and are there incentives
aligned the incentives being aligned and
you could restructure that deal and say
hey you know what you're going to get
zero percent on anything below four
hundred thousand dollars i'll give you
three percent on anything between 400
and 450 and then from 450 and up i'll
give you 20
right or 15 or whatever right and so now
they're highly incentivized to push and
now your incentives are aligned because
each increment for you is worth almost
as much it is to them and that is how
you would align incentives all right now
how do you test for the second thing
which is their skill set
this one's hard all right especially if
you don't have the perspective from
which to make a judgment which when i
enter new things when i'm trying to
learn about trust and i'm trying to
learn about investment things and
different vehicles i'm learning about
storage units more about multi like
you're like oh man there's so much stuff
there's so much nuance that you have to
have right and so the first thing is i
like to usually read two to three books
on the topic all right and i read two to
three books just so i don't appear like
an idiot um and so i can at least
understand what they're saying and
they're gonna respect you to they will
it's kind of like defense if you bring
your if you bring at least some level of
knowledge they don't feel like they're
gonna take advantage of you so this is
this is the first thing i do and this is
because i don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action i said in the
first hand which is try talk as to as
many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do is they won't do
this work right they won't take the time
to interview 20 people or 10 people when
in reality these one decisions the guy
who you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that buys x
y and z right or you or you have
somebody who manages your portfolio
whatever it is right that one decision
can be one of the most if not the
biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation then where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do i think this
person's integris do i think this person
has my best interest at heart and then
two do they have the skill to deliver on
that promise because i don't want my mom
doing my investments i know she has my
best at heart but she has no idea what
she's doing and then i don't want
somebody who absolutely knows what
they're doing and does not have my best
interests at heart right which honestly
unfortunately is a lot more of the cases
that that you'll come up with and
candidly you know a lot of times they're
literally incentivized against you you
know uh in in the insurance industry
they're they're kind of incentivized to
rip you off it's it's it's pretty
terrible and there's a lot of industries
like that mortgage brokers are
incentivized to rip you off and so you
really have to look at it from both
lenses and these types of decisions can
make the biggest impact on your net
worth in your financial future simply
based on who you decide to work with and
so
that is the framework that i think
through when i'm looking at looking for
council looking for trusted advisors
final note that i'll leave you with i
was watching a video of warren buffett
and he talked about how uh his life in
most people's life is more or less the
same he's like i eat at the same fast
food restaurants i get the same desserts
at dairy queen i wear the same suits as
you do except you know he's like or at
least they look cheap on me he said but
one thing that he he realized that was
different about him is that um he
defines a successful life based on the
number of people who truly love you when
you die and he gave a definition of that
that i thought was really powerful and
so one of his friends i can't remember
the name he said survived auschwitz and
he said that her judge of character of
who was a true friend and who truly
loved her was would this person hide me
if the nazis were coming and that's been
such a powerful frame for me to think
through which is it's not just you know
will this person trying to help me lots
of people try and help other people but
how many people help other people when
their own lives are at risk just for
helping because it's doing the right
thing and so i think when when i think
about that type of frame the number of
people i have in my life that meet that
characteristic are far and few between
and i think that if you can if you can
trust the people that you do business
with to that degree you will be best
served and if i have to choose between
the two i would rather have somebody who
i trust their intention and i have eight
an eight out of ten on the efficacy than
somebody who whose intentions i am
unsure of and they have a 10 on 10 of
the efficacy so anyways lots of love
hope you enjoyed this uh click subscribe
if you did uh and i'll see you guys next
video keep being awesome bye